et maman tu peux me déposer tu es prêt à
partir maintenant ouais j'en ai pour 10
secondes
[Musique]
je suis d'accord avec toi merci pourquoi
tu es d'accord avec elle
[Musique]
c'était le vrai zikicats merci d'être
venu
maman
t'a ouvert ma porte pendant que je merde
désolé tu as essayé d'ouvrir ma porte
pendant mon stream
j'ai environ 20 000 abonnés et je suis
validé je suis certifié ce qui est
difficile à obtenir attention à ne pas
jouer de plus quoi c'est incroyablement
immoral que des personnes blanches
jouent de la musique douce
alternatives je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire et là vous avez appelé la police je
les ai appelés vous êtes en sécurité et
vous aurez deux lits pour aussi
longtemps que vous en aurez besoin
c'est vrai que les enfants sont des
boules d'amour vous voyez ce que je veux
dire
qu'est-ce que tu fais j'installe une
balise lumineuse pour que les gens
sachent quand je stream
[Musique]
t'es pas obligé de t'intéresser à la
politique
non non j'ai pas dit ça je t'ai apporté
cette casquette elle est tellement fils
et il ne l'apporte plus je sais plus ce
qu'il porte
la plupart des garçons de ton âge
n'arrive pas à être gentil arrête Ziggy
toi tu ne peux pas t'en empêcher tu es
très spécial
[Musique]
tu es heureux tu crois ouais pourquoi tu
me demandes ça parce que je suis en
train de lire un article fascinant sur
le suicide chez les adolescents ok merci
papa maman est rentré
quand tu étais petit j'étais mon petit
allié tu aurais pu faire en sorte
d'avoir une vie plus heureuse tu aurais
été le meilleur d'entre nous et quelque
chose a changé en toi
bah arrêtez de t'intéresser à tout ce
qui était en dehors de ton petit monde
désolé pour ça
[Musique]
tu peux m'emmener au lycée tu es prêt à
partir maintenant à ton avis
[Musique]